I love seeing you so much obviously I'm
not going to see you tonight you're not
going to come out no I gotta I gotta go
back to the old the old uh don't say
family don't say it I know it's a bad
word what are you doing tonight you have
a pool at your house no
you have a pool nearby in your
neighborhood yeah let your kids go
swimming and then look the other way
problem solved
we had an LA inspector guy come to my
house and literally say you know it's
illegal to not have a fence around your
pool yeah same I think that's a lot and
I said why yeah because it because if
the pools were built at a certain era
they didn't have to appeal to that or
abide by that law yeah and he said you
know a kid could come in back here this
is where I just said that from him he
was like a kid couldn't come back here
falling and die I go well it might help
out that family you never know he didn't
even crack he didn't crack smile you got
to be around a comedian for that joke I
know he did not like it did his face was
not offended it was like angry